MENTIONED MARIOTA EARLIER. I
DID ONE OF US. DID WE BOTH
DID? I THINK MARIO TO NOW ON
THE RAIDERS DEPTH CHART? BUT
NOT IN THE BUILDING YET
BECAUSE IT WAS ROOKIE
MINICAMP FOR LAS VEGAS.
I STILL CAN'T GET A FEEL FOR
WHERE THE RAIDERS ARE RIGHT
NOW. YOU LOOK AT THE
DECONSTRUCTION OF THE
OFFENSIVE LINE AND THEN THE
PARTIAL RECONSTRUCTION OF THE
OFF,
BACK GUYS, LIKE RICHIE ING
INCOGNITO, THEN THE FIRST
ROUND DECISION TO TAKE ALEX
LEATHERWOOD WHEN CHRISTIAN
DHARA SAW WAS AVAILABLE. AND
A LOT OF CRITICISM OF THE
RAIDERS FOR THAT. ONE OF THE
ONLY TEAMS THAT GOT E OF THE
ROUND PICK. BECAUSE THE WHOLE
ETIQUETTE AT THIS POINT IS
PRAISE AND HYPE. PRAISE AND
HYPE EVERYONE. HOPE HOPE HOPE
GLASS HALF FULL EXCEPT FOR
ALEX. LEATHERWOOD. GOING TO
THE RAIDERS IS KIND OF A
WEIRD VIBE RIGHT NOW WITH
THAT TEAM AND THERE WAS NO
REAL NEWS THAT CAME OUT OF
THERE.
KEY MINI CAMP THIS WEEKEND,
I GUESS IS GOOD NEWS. BUT YOU
KNOW, THAT'S, THAT'S THAT'S
KIND OF WHERE WE ARE. YEAH,
THEY GOTTA THEY GONNA LIKE
THE LAS VEGAS, RAIDERS. IT'S
LIKE YOU'RE RIGHT. THERE'S NO
THEME OR ANYTHING TO HIT ON.
IT'S LIKE LAS VEGAS, RAIDERS
2021, PROVE IT. THAT'S WHAT
LIKE, THEIR LOGO. PROVE IT
YEAH, YOUNG GUYS, THAT YOU'VE
BEEN DRAFTED, PROVE THAT
YOU'RE WORTHY OF THE JOB JON
GRUDEN, YOU KNOW?
BIG YEAR GOING TO THE YEAR
FOR FOR PROVE IT THAT YOU'RE
WORTHY OF IT. DEREK CARR.
YEAH. YOU SHOWED US LAST YEAR.
I MEAN TO ME IT'S JUST ABOUT
NOW. THEY GOING TO START
GROOMING SOME OF THESE YOUNG
GUYS THAT THEY'VE DRAFTED AND
THEY GOT IT'S LIKE TIME TO
PUT UP OR SHUT UP THERE WITH
THE RAIDERS TO A DEGREE NOT
THAT THEY GOT TO GO TO THE
A DEGREE, NOT THAT THEY GOT
TO GO TO THE PLAYOFFS AND
THEY ARE AT THE POINT WHERE?
YEAH, THEY'RE A TEAM THAT WE
SAW AN IMPROVEMENT FROM LAST
YEAR, YOU KNOW, TO A DEGREE.
MAYBE NOT QUITE THE WAY WE
WERE EXPECTING AT THE END OF
THE YEAR. I THINK
THE MIX A LITTLE BIT MORE IN
KIND OF, LIKE, MADE THINGS A
LITTLE DISAPPOINTING WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT THE RAIDERS
OVERALL. SO THAT'S WHERE IT
IS A BIG YEAR, BECAUSE
JUST SO MANY UNPROVEN
COMMODITIES, WHETHER IT BE
DRAFT PICKS, FREE AGENT
SIGNINGS, THE COACHES,
WHATEVER IT JUST HASN'T ALL
COME TOGETHER THERE QUITE YET
TO BE ANYTHING SPECIAL AND
THAT'S WHERE IT'S LIKE, YOU
JUST DON'T KNOW WHICH WAY
THIS TEAM IS TEETERING RIGHT
NOW.
ESPECIALLY WITH THIS
RECONSTRUCTION OF THE OFFENSE
OF LINE AND AN INTERESTING
AN EYE ON AS IT RELATES TO
RAIDERS. COACH JON GRUDEN.
FROM HIM THE ENTIRE YEAR, D
SINCE THE REGULAR SEASON
ENDED IN THE RAIDERS FOR THE
THIRD, STRAIGHT SEASON UNDER
GRUDEN, DID NOT MAKE IT TO
THE PLAYOFFS. HE DID THAT.
CRIS COLLINSWORTH PODCAST
WITH RICHARD SHERMAN, OPENLY
TAMPERED WITH SHERMAN, DURING
PODCAST, THERE HAS BEEN
NOTHING ELSE FROM GRUDEN.
NOTHING, PRE FREE AGENCY.
FREE AGENCY PRE-DRAFT DURING
DRAFT POST DRAFT THIS PAST
ACCESS OR ZOOM AVAILABILITY
FOR ANYONE. NO ROOKIES, NO
COACHES, NO ONE. AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE'S
SOME PRESSURE BEING PUT ON
SOME OF THESE TEAMS VIA THE
PRO FOOTBALL WRITERS
ASSOCIATION TO MAKE GUYS
AVAILABLE. THE REPORTERS
CAN'T BE THERE BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. TEAMS ARE CHOOSING
TEAMS AREN'T AVAILABLE SOME
AND WITH THE RAIDERS ARE
THAN MIKE MAYOCK. YEAH, ABLE
RIGHT. MAYOCK IS AVAILABLE IN
AVAILABLE IN AVAILABLE
GRUDEN'S. NOWHERE TO BE SEEN
THE PLAYERS ARE NOWHERE TO BE
SEEN AS JUST KIND OF A
STRANGE THING RIGHT NOW, AND
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE JUST
TRYING TO SET UP AN US
WHAT BRUTON'S UPSET. HE GOT
CALLED OUT FOR TAMPERING
WITH RICHARD SHERMAN. WELL,
YOU KNOW WHAT ONE WAY TO
AVOID THAT DON'T TAMPER WITH
RICHARD SHERMAN EITHER WAY.
GRUDEN IS NOWHERE TO BE SEEN
AND IT IS KIND OF STRANGE AND
IT GETS MORE CONSPICUOUS AS
IT GOES ON. IT DOES WELL. I
KNOW THAT, LIKE, I TEXTED YOU
RIGHT. I THINK ROUND ONE LIKE
I DID, I DIDN'T REWIND AND GO
BACK AND LOOK, BUT MAYBE I
NEED TO, I DON'T THINK GRUDEN
WAS IN THE ROOM DURING ROUND
ONE WITH ALEX LEATHER, MORE
THAN THE PICK, YOU KNOW, WHEN
THEY SHOWED THE RAIDERS WERE
ROOM AND PEOPLE
CONGRATULATING EACH OTHER AND
DOING ALL THAT, THERE WAS NO
GRUDEN TO BE FOUND. I KNOW
THAT WAS ODD, LET ALONE ALL
THE OTHER THINGS THAT YOU'VE
JUST TALKED ABOUT. SO, I
DON'T KNOW. IT IS A BIG YEAR
FOR THAT, THAT FOOTBALL TEAM
IN THAT ORGANIZATION, YOU
LIKE I SAID, IT'S JUST A LOT
YOU KNOW, WE HEARD IT FROM
MAYOCK A LITTLE BIT, YOU KNOW,
GUYS WHO THEY'VE COMMITTED
TO, WHETHER IT'S MONEY, DROP
PICKS OR WHATEVER, LIKE, IT'S
GOT TO BE BETTER, IT'S JUST
GOT TO BE BETTER, WHETHER
SAFETY, GOT TO BE BETTER,
WHETHER IT'S JONATHAN ABRAMS
AT SAFETY, GOT TO BE BETTER.
DAMON ARNETT, KEEPING HIS
COOL AND, YOU KNOW, PLAYING
THE RIGHT WAY. GOT TO BE
PLAYING THE RIGHT WAY. GOT TO
BE BETTER THERE. YOUR HEARD
ALL OF THOSE TYPE OF THINGS.
SO, YOU KNOW, THAT'S WHERE
IT'S GOING TO BE INTERESTING.
HENRY, RUGS TOP 15, PICK OF
RECEIVER. YEAH, IT WAS GOOD
LAST YEAR BUT IT'S GOT TO BE
BETTER TO BE A TOP 15 PICK. I
LIKE THE WHOLE TEAM IS LIKE,
THE THEME YOU COULD JUST
CONTINUALLY SAY LIKE YEAH
OKAY BUT IT'S GOTTA BE BETTER.
LIKE THAT'S WHAT IT'S GOT TO
BE. THERE'S NO MARQUIS UNIT
OR ANYTHING TO LOOK AT ON THE
TEAM RIGHT NOW TO JUST GO.
WOW THEY GOT THAT AND IF THEY
CAN BUILD AROUND THAT THEN
THEY'RE GOING TO BE OKAY.
EVERYTHING'S LIKE YOU SAID
IT'S KIND OF LIKE I'M NOT
SURE. YEAH IT'S OKAY. OKAY.
THAT'S NOT A GREAT WAY TO
ESPECIALLY NOT WITH THE
KANSAS CITY CHIEFS IN THE
DIVISION. THAT'S YES, THE
CHARGERS. YEAH. READY TO
IMPROVE DRAMATICALLY IN
JUSTIN HERBERT SECOND YEAR
WITH BRANDON STALEY, IS THE
HEAD COACH THE BRONCOS
GETTING MENTIONED REPEATEDLY.
AND IT TOOK US TWENTY SIX
MINUTES TO MENTION AARON
RODGERS, BUT THEY'RE TIED TO
AARON RODGERS, AND AND THE
RAY DOESN'T CHALLENGE, ROGERS,
ON THE THE ROGERS WHISTLE
LIST AND THERE'S BEEN NO SIGN,
NO INDICATION, NO SENSE, THE
ARE EVEN REMOTELY INTERESTED
RODGERS, WHICH  AT AARON
SEEMS BIZARRE. IF HE WANTS
YOU. DON'T YOU AT LEAST
EXPLORE ISN'T THERE
SOMETHING? AND I KNOW THAT
THEY YOU KNOW THEY'RE ALL IN
WITH DEREK CARR AND YEAH I
DON'T KNOW YOU. WELL STILL IF
YOU COULD TAKE DEREK CARR,
AARON RODGERS, CHRIS YOU'RE
TAKING AARON RODGERS.
DOUBT ABOUT IT, NO DOUBT BUT
I GUESS THEY'RE HERE'S THE
THINGS THAT THE COME TO MY
MIND WHEN YOU HEAR THAT ONE.
YEAH. DEREK CARR, THEY
PROGRAM. THE ROBOT LIKE
YOU'VE TALKED TO ME LIKE
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT BUT THAT'S
NOT GOING TO BE LIKE MAKE IT
THE OTHER THING IS IS LIKE,
YEAH, AARON RODGERS IS GREAT,
BUT WE JUST TALKED ABOUT
THEIR DAMN TEAM AND THEN LIKE,
YEAH, AND IT'S LIKE FIRST
OFF, YOU KNOW, OKAY. YOU
TRADE THAT AND WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO HAVE AS A TEAM, WHAT
GOT TO TRADE AWAY, MORE
FUTURE ASSETS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT TO WHERE YOU JUST GO.
THE HELL CAN WE POSSIBLY?
BUILD HERE, WE DON'T HAVE A
GREAT FOUNDATION AND NOW WE
DON'T HAVE THE BRICKS TO LAY
THE REST OF THE HOUSE. SO
THERE'S THAT ASPECT. AND THEN
WITH THE RAIDERS WOULD ALWAYS
COMES TO MY MIND IS, CAN THEY
WE'VE HEARD ENOUGH RUMORS
OVER THE LAST YEAR'S TO, THEY
HAVE THE CASH TO PAY A ROGERS
OR STUFF LIKE THAT. THOSE ARE
THREE THINGS THAT AT LEAST
POP TO MY HEAD. INSTANTLY
MAYBE WHY WE DON'T HEAR THEM.
SO HOT WITH THE ROGER
SITUATION YOU MOVED TO LAS
VEGAS TO OPEN A NEW STADIUM
IN. YOU HAVE NO FANS AT ALL
RIGHT HERE. THAT AFFECTED THE
CASH FLOW AS WELL FOR THE
RAIDERS, BUT ROGERS TO THE
BRONCOS WOULD MAKE IT EVEN
HARDER FOR THE RAIDERS TO BE
ANYTHING OTHER THAN, YEAH, AT
BEST, THE THIRD PLACE TEAM IN
THE AFC WEST,
BE THE ONE TEAM. KEEPING THE
AFC WEST AT THAT POINT FROM
BEING TOP TO BOTTOM, ONE OF
THE BEST DIVISIONS IN THE NF
L MEAN AND EVEN THEN THEY
COULD GO NINE AND EIGHT EIGHT
NINE AND AND STILL BE IN LAST
PLACE. YEAH, IN THAT DIVISION,
THE WAY IT'S CURRENTLY GOING
FROM ONE OF THE STRONGEST
DIVISIONS. TO ONE OF THE
WEAKEST, THE AFC SOUTH, WHICH
SHOWS FLASHES FROM TIME TO
TIME, BUT PERPETUALLY
ALL FOUR TEAMS, THE WORST IN
THE